I like this episode more than the latest
Mandalore
I did not think I should say that what
is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation we are here to watch the
bad batch season two finale working off
of a couple hours of sleep after
Mandalorian I was a little overly
ambitious but I'm I'm awake now I'm
ready to go I had a great night's sleep
well Greg was editing away oh I'm G
fueled up I mean I haven't started yet
but I'm about to start you'll see me
wake up throughout the reaction but guys
please go ahead use the force to leave a
like that'd be very much appreciated
they should also watch the reaction then
Michael John and I did for mandalorians
yeah if you haven't watched it already
I'm a little surprised full length and
watch along to be sync with your own
copy bad hash available for a super sexy
rejection at our patreon page we cover a
bunch of stuff exclusively over there I
should give mentioned we got a new shirt
exclusive from the real rejects
Department look at it I think it speaks
for itself I don't care what anyone says
this is the coolest thing we've ever
created I think it's brilliant look at
that look at the text it's smart was it
your brainchild
yeah yeah of course it was genius once
in a while I come up with something I go
that's smart I don't care what anyone
says I'm gonna credit myself on how
smart I am
and then I remind myself that I am full
of
full of self-loathing
let's go
[Music]
the summit summit Hemlock set to attend
a high-level Imperial Summit in two
rotations tarkan's Compound on eriodu oh
cool
well then
let's get started
[Music]
excited so where are you all headed
covet mission
oh I see
well I expect details when you get back
bye fee
what a random conversation
it was such accurate writing for a child
though
so just going to leave without saying
goodbye yeah what the hell brown eyes
you require a briefing
smooth don't go running off with any
Pirates or Smugglers while you're gone
this Mission should not involve either
it's not
really what I was getting this is so
awkward I love it yes sir you fool see
you around brown eyes
oh what is this thing rising from my
pants
[Music]
they go so hard on the music now that
we're all finally here we can begin
I love the matte painting in this series
it's just so beautiful they always make
their final episodes even extra gorgeous
we'll sneak past the sensor and hit you
right under one of the cars but I
estimate only 30 seconds for us to clear
the Zone before it reactivates we must
be precise
I love that they have hyperspace travel
but they still use cable cars of course
[Music]
a boy tick
foreign
of the batch I'm right there with you
although I do love Echo
dah
run a full system diagnostic yes sir
good on him surprisingly thoughtful for
an imperial halfway there
isn't so bad
you spoke too soon
I made me nauseous
[Music]
I like the T for Tarkin and the building
murder that
they're not stun anymore
because they're not clones no that was a
straight up also he just fell off yeah
that's what I mean you still falling
previously known only to the Kim and
Owens we will ensure an enlightened
society and with more clone troopers
being decommissioned I have found a new
purpose for them and these clones have
agreed to your experimentation
I served with the club for many years
are we all willing to just dismiss them
out of hand he's partner for the empire
under Jedi leadership they adopted a
concerning level of individuality
we will deal with them swiftly and
unilaterally to quell any threat of a
clone Uprising oh there it is Lone
Rebellion Enlighten us to the status of
project Stardust ah speak Rogue one yes
thank you thanks for the reminder you're
welcome I'm often a one-hit wonder guy
with Star Wars watch it all once at
least it's all it's all connected Craig
not the best of remembering names and
I'll monitor their
security that's stun that was stun I
wonder it's because those are
non-combatants how quick do they decide
on whether to set it to stun or kill
surveillance systems have had cycle
deactivations in various corridors that
is highly irregular considering the
number of top-ranking Imperial officers
present hmm I've got a
interesting sensation
I'll keep it
up I wonder if there's another Rebel
cell or something here Honda would knock
it yep yep let's go there might as well
final episode
I feel like I'm watching GoldenEye right
now
[Music]
bacon is secure
oh
[Music]
Star Wars Rebels is this
oops you wrecked it another offline
camera
it's unsuspicious just I feel like
somebody else might be here a thermal
explosive
someone is targeting this base
you have more
is that a clone
I didn't expect to find YouTube oh no
you had a choice to make looks like
you've chosen I'm leveling this compound
along with all the Imperials inside it
that suck at the Seesaw have you
considered that by destroying this
facility you are wiping out any chance
to gather Intel that could help your
cause how's he supposed to turn into
Forest Whitaker in like two weeks that
Victory will be short-lived as their
ranks will quickly be replenished its
sacrifices have to be made for the
greater good sacrifice
mate
yeah that's such a good impression
I gotta say it sound looks real good
though
[Music]
oh yeah
yeah tech oh oh Sean wicking it
we have to hit the command center
get to a shuttle before they find to
disarm the explosives I recognize that
other voice
so katano
we will resume momentarily take your
seat gentlemen
[Laughter]
see we are perfect
yes Council room is also my Panic Room
King's Landing theme song right here
[Music]
didn't he secure the rail we need an
access code I'll override it
[Music]
ah that was badass
if you're a nurse who's probably too
young huh
Yeah by a lot ignore me
Oh I thought I was gonna hit the top of
that
[Music]
oh my God
nicely done man
your up
[Laughter]
oh yeah
oh
Electro
[Music]
if Sid saves them I'm I'm done it showed
up for this is going to be a
problem
[Music]
oh my God
that sucks just on a non-batter level
that sucks in a I was I was on my way to
go skiing for the evening and I got
stuck level all right let's watch the
next one
5.99 I got 99 plans but uh
beautiful shot you three give us cover
Tech
do we think everyone's making it out
No Maybe
I don't know
[Music]
I feel like they've teased killing Tech
somebody they kill lovers just thinking
that would they kill off Tech that would
hurt the most I think it should be
Wrecker
[Music]
okay
but it should be an accident it's
not just inconsequential it's an
important lesson for Omega
just like that
six detonations confirmed multiple
casualties reported sir we've engaged
insurgents trap sorry didn't mean to
step into your hologram
they couldn't get caught in the
crossfire I am aware do it
such a good leader he's willing to
sacrifice his people that's the
difference between Tarkin and thrawn
thrawn would have captured them
interrogated them Target just blow stuff
up
oh that's ominous yeah sagrera where did
you go
[Applause]
oh Lord oh my God they're gonna kill off
Tech
no it requires some courage
it's a lot of Courage for them to do
oh no I'm so worried for him
oh
[Applause]
don't do it
no I'm so scared for him
oh
man
oh you gotta be kidding me
that's not great I got like serious
Goosebumps right now
[Music]
oh why aren't we moving
are they gonna actually do it Cosby
ripped from the trash
oh no
oh no any shifted weight could set both
of these cars over oh you gotta be
kidding me
he's just saying he's my favorite
daughter
must
it's a connection here
[Music]
hinge there is no time Wrecker
9.99 oh my god wow
nothing to attack
what the ugh
when have we ever
oh what
[Music]
is my favorite one
poor Omega all the she's gone
through damn
I can't stop it oh man
[Music]
that's like a real serious turn man oh
wow maybe he like landed on a per gallon
oh man
I didn't even say goodbye to
feet I mean there's no way you could
have survived that tick
oh man
[Music]
horror Omega she has a hard enough time
when people take vacations away from the
badge
imagine
oh my God
whoa
it's POV we have to get around here
Call of Duty Modern Warfare
whoa this is very different I would
watch an entire show just like this
how disorienting
holy
Star Wars animations for kids
I don't know
she's to be fair these are a few and far
between I could
what happened did we find the treasure
Tech didn't make it
we have to go back what if he's hurt he
he needs us poor guy Jake
Jake's gone
[Music]
he can't be
oh man
ugh you get that feeling of just shock
that runs over your heart that's where
I'm at right now it's time to put being
soldiers behind us
for good
wrecker and I think Pabu could be a good
place to make a new life for ourselves
is that something you want that's nice
across here oh my God said uh no no
let's go in there shoot her in the head
here
this one's on the house wow it will help
get on him I always liked him me too
that's uncomfortable where's that look
she gave I don't know I don't like it
the Empire's here
Hunter do you copy
wrecker oh she totally turned them into
the Empire oh my God
so much no what do you think that look
was I don't want to believe your
assumption yet but you might be right
oh she's feeling guilty no way you gotta
be me what's with you
you know I tried to look out for you
boys oh you you got too much heat
on you and you brought it here to my
place of business I gotta make the best
of a bad situation what is happening in
this episode
[Music]
Omega you and AC need to go that's an
order
I like this episode more than the latest
Mandalorian
snakes are hot I did not think I didn't
say that wow this this hasn't taken so
many dark turns I can't do it Izzy I'm
not gonna lose him too
oh
how sexy that is
oh boy
it's all that silent sad I hate it the
Empire thanks you for your assistance
police killer give us that our business
is done
leave
where I live
oh God I hate said I hate her so much
Omega is not going anywhere with you
oh who knew clones are so paternal oh
God he talks down to them
oh yes Tech
you don't get to talk about them
I'm afraid this was all I could Salvage
oh sheesh so he's definitely dead or is
this Salvage and if you don't lower the
Blaster now you
get
God I hate you Sid
[Music]
yeah
omega's not going anywhere with you
[Music]
I'll try to store them as long as I can
they've got a lot to wrap up and not a
lot of time right now I'm pretty sure
we're gonna cliffhang it
oh damn
maybe nothing smart is cool Omega
hello Omega
[Music]
and we do the opposite
I think it's going to end exactly how we
thought
Darth Maul
it was Hemlock we've got to stop his
shovel from leaving I think we put a
thing around Omega the rest of the batch
gets away
and he's injured through all this poor
guy
they should have stayed on Pabu I don't
know why they didn't just go to Pabu
[Music]
this is tragic man oh my gosh
sad omega's gone but it's a bit of a
weight off my shoulders it's a lot a lot
more quiet
[Music]
we are going to get her back
and we don't stop searching oh man
[Music]
at least she has a friend
why did they bring me here
stop snooking around what he seeks is
not possible make it possible
across here
of course here I don't really get a lot
of time together
[Music]
is that your real mother you must be
Omega
ironic
you trust the camera no one
but not me
I don't know
no you're right
maybe
you might your mind
[Music]
we're sisters
Omega sisters
called it that first episode when we
heard hers well we all know genetics
pass along accents that's just how that
you're born with it
[Music]
oh wow
wow oh man that's great that was a great
finale that was a fantastic finale yeah
how to get a third season 101
um they should make the next season 24
episodes I think it should be 50
episodes every
fourth episode I feel something
cinematic I feel like the gang can only
rescue Omega if they find the treasure
first yeah I think we need more treasure
hunts and I think they need to get back
with say because they need money anyway
to go find a mate I mean
um let's let's we could we could bullet
point this really fast look yeah okay
there's some main things to talk about
because we're doing things we really
gotta focus on right
let's talk about tech may he rest in
peace maybe maybe you know the rules of
some resting in pieces the rule of thumb
with fandom yeah
if you don't see it happen you don't see
it happen I'm not gonna lie this is one
of those cases where I'm not sure I'd
want to see it happen at that velocity
and distance they've teased the the
threat of him dying a couple of times
especially in this I remember the first
episode of this series first or second
episode I mean I think both of us have
said that from the get-go that he's the
they spent so much time developing him
um and I mean even his relationship with
fee I feel like to leave it on that kind
of uh
I mean it's devastating uh it's like a
Bittersweet note there yeah I mean as
much as I'd love for it and somehow Tech
survived uh maybe they clone them uh
it's Star Wars no I know I just I I like
when the consequences
have consequences you know I don't I
prefer all my characters to temporarily
die and then come back
in an animated form animated form or in
a prequel or an in-between call
yeah no it the the tension was high uh I
mean throughout the whole episode I mean
we really
I wish we had a little bit more time to
grieve Tech though in an episode like
this because
I know that they had the the thing where
when Echo left and then
omega's like why don't any of you talk
about your feelings
that was literally me to my family
before starting therapy that was that
that was there that episode Echo but
um that was different he was saying bye
and they're kind of used to you know
moving away and stuff this is the death
of their brother yeah and I wish we had
a tiny bit more time well I I think
that's
even the the change in cinematography uh
and just that like I mean it was like
Modern Warfare 2 like straight out of
one of the cut scenes there is a great
visual uh and I think just getting that
POV but I I feel like as as much as I
wish we had more time to take that and
sit with it I also appreciated how
dramatic like okay we're finally gonna
get a reprieve to collect ourselves sure
only to immediately get betrayed
um let's talk about that now yeah Sid
this better be the freaking nail in the
coffin we've been done with Sid for like
I a long time now I I think that
Sid is a good person
no it's so
it's so infuriating it's that's exactly
what it is it's infuriating because it's
a betrayal like they have made her the
most frustrating character yeah and the
Betrayal was so
like two on the nose
um and like I imagine what they were
trying to go for is like Orlando
betraying like Han and Company uh and
Empire type but it did not come off as
that yeah it just came off as like this
is a literal piece of trash you were
like it comes across like an addict in a
way yeah just keep coming back for more
like why didn't they just go to Pabu I'm
saying she comes across like an addict
like I can't help myself
yeah I have to protect myself and oh no
matter how many times that you have like
stuck your neck out for me I have to
pray oh God that was so infuriating uh
like I want her dead
please animate it yeah I mean I think
the the setup here
um
part of me wonders uh if we don't get a
season three and if we do get a film uh
not a live action film an animated film
come on um or a a clone Rebellion
miniseries what's gonna happen is this
is gonna get canceled
and then there'll be a Resurgence after
a big demand and then I I don't know if
we're gonna have a big demand on this
one I don't know I I don't feel like
this was trending on Twitter hashtag the
bad batch and then I went now that I see
it's trending I better log off Twitter
because big episode yeah yeah I mean I
I really I think that
You can conclude this story arc with a
clone Rebellion miniseries like uh I've
I have
I just don't know where they go after
this
um I mean after they eventually have to
save Omega and would you get out you tie
it in just keep keep finding more plots
to tie it in yeah we saw the the
Omega is the only Survivor
and she becomes a foundling in the
Mandalorian yeah a dude and then she
becomes the armorer
the scenario that is not entirely
terrified yes because the armor is like
yellow
it doesn't matter
oh guys
um sagarrera turns into Forest Whitaker
at some point that's true crazier things
have happened in the Star Wars Universe
in fact whoever plays Sakura in animated
does not care at all to be like I'm
gonna try to come across like I could
transition it hasn't it hasn't been that
jarring uh since Rebels had Obi-Wan
Kenobi in it like like the time yeah
like wow they just went straight to Alec
Guinness I could still see a scenario
where because because there's such a
sparing Gap at how freaking old elegant
is this versus Kevin McGregor well and
and I felt like in the Obi-Wan and they
were good enough track here but I felt
like in the Obi-Wan series they had the
opportunity to like bring it a little
closer to the middle yeah you know be
like yeah the Tatooine Sun not great on
your skin yeah you know but no they just
but but the Forest Whitaker jump I mean
it's like is drastically different
interpretations yeah I mean even if they
like extended his voice a little bit I
mean like your impression just really
put it into Clarity for me how
ridiculous it is because they even have
like Jedi oh my God what is it we call
it fall in order Fallen order or Force
Whitaker Sakura is in that yeah and this
is not just too far I would say like
it's like two weeks it was a rough it
was like a rough five years for all
these characters
I mean he had a freaking oxygen mask
yeah it is not great uh for saw
um yeah I mean
anyway
I'm I'm excited yeah at the prospect of
another whatever it may be I'm getting
you on track here purposely Michael
Sister Sister scientist yeah so I called
it
um You didn't say did you say sister I
said the clone of I think it's I think
we can tell it's like they're of the
same DNA similar voice actor or similar
similarities which I think is the
funniest way to communicate that because
again
if my parents were born in Britain but I
was raised in America I would have a
British accent right
it's because it's a reason it's in my
genetics yeah
uh no I mean I think that's the funny
silly part but I guess that's maybe just
the accent they got growing up on kamino
um no I mean I think that's super
curious I mean it does kind of open up
the like yeah if the Kevin Owens are
known for cloning it stands to reason
that before Jango Fett they made clones
um yeah what for and who for I think is
actually a really interesting notion
um
to do I've always thought it would be
great if I could clone myself to do my
responsibilities have you seen my
Severance is that what Severance is
about pretty much oh no I've never
wanted to watch Severance until now
that's festivity out there
um is that the flood of severance really
no that's pretty much the plot oh man I
had a whole like for years I had an idea
about that like oh we cool to see a
story about and then like the Clones
like Rebel is that what happens so it's
not exactly clones uh but it's it's
basically don't tell me I'm already
it's one of the best shows I've
officially interested right Severance
available at Apple TV does uh
I'll react to that with you I'd love to
read it's just a mind did you already
watch it though it doesn't matter it
does matter
it matters here it matters here you know
re-react here we don't re-react oh I
feel it is that that's a good way to
recycle popular we're going to re-react
to things a couple years out
of three react regions of this pilot
reactions
the real to real ah I'm always trying to
Champion for that title for stuff anyway
so yeah the sister and uh yeah I mean
was she in with the empire was she in
with the Kevin Owens I think the
interesting thing is
based on her age
so there's kind of two things here like
one is she like the the typical clones
that age at twice the rate of a normal
person or has she ate well she's a
wellness so she's got to be a lot older
too
I mean
right
like if you're 30 as a woman it really
60 isn't that the rule
I thought this was common knowledge
maybe to you Greg but
I prefer to to sleep in my bed at night
this is
yes Craig that's why your wife is making
me sleep on the couch I always thought
she was just a stubborn pain in the ass
getting confirmed she's the opposite
she's lovely we love your wife she's
great
um no well because the interesting thing
that I'm wondering is uh if she has been
alive for the amount of years that she
has lived and she doesn't have that age
acceleration
um because it doesn't Omega doesn't age
Omega does age just at a normal rate I
thought I'd make a dozen age no a mega
will always be a child I really thought
that's what her situation was no really
no for some reason my mind my memory
that's the funniest thing I've ever
heard this whole time she's Immortal I
thought she was like wait no I thought
she how old is she what she's the same
age as Boba
it's the same way that Boba is a clone
that ages at the normal aging rate for a
human yes it's the same thing for I mean
I believe you no there's nothing to
believe it's just the fact Greg in that
that season two
oh she is just 13 I thought she was like
30. I really thought this whole time my
memory was serving me vastly incorrect
oh my God I thought she was just as
awesome so my point is if that's right
okay yeah because if clone has made the
accelerate super fast and that solution
the sister is a generation one clone
okay
uh-huh
that means
that she's been alive before the Clone
Wars and maybe this was all part of
Palpatine's plan I wonder I and this is
something that's always like drove me
crazy like the cypho Diaz like Arc and
all of that about like yeah let's all be
super cool with the random clone army
that was pre-made very conveniently at
the start of this war
um and I feel like it would be really
interesting to explore the emperor's
fascination
with clones prior emperor's new batch
you need sleep
uh do we have a shout out of the day
it was just thinking interesting our
shout out of the day
yeah
this one is it goes out to my homie my
brother
Greg Albert Greg let's wrap Greg has
been a real reject for a wrap up the
final thoughts here Michael I thought
this was better than the latest
Mandalorian episode that we had even
though people love it because the rebels
character that shows up and everyone's
like Yay best episode ever
um but uh I I mean that's not the only
reason why people say that I I think
that this this had such great dramatic
tension and weight and suspense and the
the last episode especially especially
compared to the the first season finale
which kind of went about as you expected
this just kept taking turns and I was
like unbelie what like yeah death uh
turn of the character and then reveal
you know they they did they did a lot
here and I thought it breathed really
well I thought it was excellently done
and yeah and I can't wait for all 15 000
of you people to watch this video so my
final thoughts oh my God my final
thoughts people one
I like the season one finale better oh
you I I thought Camino sinking was
just a devastating uh
all of it was that was part one of the
film that's that's fair that's totally
fair
um but also the the robot that we didn't
see all season the robot the Droid we
didn't see all season uh that we only
got for like the last episode yeah um
saving them was beautiful
um but no I I I'm I'm proud of the show
I hope I mean I hate saying it but I
hope Tech stays dead because that was a
brave choice and Tech dead Pee Wee trick
borders
remember that
yes Tech every Tech dead View
well
I just want to say thank you to all of
reject Nation for having me on for bad
batch this was a wonderful introduction
thank God you were here so this premium
or sorry
what's that from you mean Rogue one
what's that guy's name
count count what was the Count's name
Dooku sometimes Star Wars feels you know
when you're in class at like actual
school I you probably never had this
problem I vote I've had this problem I
graduated with a 2.0 correct I had
whatever before I get so caught up and
remember this pay attention and I'm
thinking that so much consciously that I
have now missed the information because
I'm thinking so much about that and that
has happened with me so much when
binging clone wars and Rebels and and
everything else
so yeah it didn't find out the whole
time when I thought Omega was way over I
was like what why did I think that what
is the PowerHouse of the cell what what
is the PowerHouse of the cell what is
that it's the mitochondria come on this
is it what are you talking about what
what's the green stuff in a plant cell
that makes it different from a non
pretended a Star Wars thing no I'm
talking I'm talking High School facts
for you Greg No I barely even know what
photosynthesis
what is it something about sun and
plants
and there you have it
you don't need to be educated to make it
on YouTube no you don't that's the
example I wish to lead anyway guys we
should do a patron of the day shot
before we do actually subscribe leave a
like follow Michael Jesus we got to end
this I gotta edit this
you were the last Patron to shout out of
the month of the patron of the day shout
out Brian I would love to clone you make
multiple clones of you and assign you to
each part of my rooms in this home that
way I make sure it is under constant
surveillance and constant cleaning that
is what I see you as Brian a potential
servant and I want you to serve me
through the roof and underneath my roof
in every possible way but I don't mean
that in a sexual way because that's
inappropriate I would just use you for
strictly consistent manual labor so
Brian I hope you can understand that
this is a compliment that I would love
for you to constantly clean cook
clean out the toilet because I got a
condition so you gotta constantly clean
that and confirm he has it's bad it's a
bad condition it's a bad batch it's a
bad match
so yeah buddy
um and next month I will shout you out
using your last name Perry linking you
to the cast of Friends Matthew Perry who
plays Chandler I would keep a love
teasing Matthew Perry is and Friends
huh I want something new every day
have you not seen friends
what you've seen no comment could you be
any more foolish it um no if I was I'd
be Greg ah Brian thank you so much for
being part of our patreon Paige and um I
love all of you's the use being the
multiple use that are going to be here
in this home alrighty
peace out reject Nation May the force be
with you
[Music]